what's about your genealogy show it is
so good and it's and it's so well done
it's called who do you think you are and
you get these in you know a lot of
people a lot of celebrities to give
their DNA yeah and then you and and and
I'll also provide provide information
yeah but you get their DNA which means
you could plant all that at different
murder scenes all the murderer was just
you know Angela Lansbury there's another
good show I framed a celebrity who
thought they were providing genealogy I
have so many good ideas for you but you
know it's interesting I am we talked
about this before but I'm still curious
I gave you guys my history and DNA like
three years ago right and you were like
trust me you Conan you're gonna be
related to all these really famous
people and I kind of warned you I don't
think so right never heard a word back
from you guys yeah not a word and I know
they're still scratching around they are
they are we haven't given up hope right
but the notes I keep getting back are
you know well the American stories he
knows everything you know everything
about the American side yeah yeah he was
a cop she was a cop and that as a cop
and you know no we were all like we all
moved here when moved to central
Massachusetts but what I found out
recently which I wasn't thinking you
aware of I just had my my DNA tested and
the doctor said I've never seen this
before you're 100% Irish 100 he said no
no no don't apply
it means I'm inbred it just doesn't go
back far enough you've got red hair
doesn't that mean Viking yeah yeah a
Viking a viking got it on with somebody
but no it really was it's you know it's
one of those things were but you talked
to a lot of celebrities you find all
kinds of stuff that's any stuff about
them oh my god great we'll just coming
up as Jean smart mm that's gonna be on
Monday well to me the interval there's a
lot of interesting I know it's like the
most thrilling thing I could ever do
this show it's I'm really anyway fun
yeah stopping an interview to turn to
the crowd I'm fun but yeah yeah yeah but
gene so gene smart okay first of all we
found an ancestor from like hundreds of
years ago and it's a woman and their
records about her and you never get to
find out about a woman from a few
hundred years ago you just rarely do but
she was like the head of a crime ring
her family this is in like the
Massachusetts Bay Colony and then the
funny thing is is gene smart was saying
how like I never wear turtlenecks I
don't like things around my neck and I
used to joke with my friends that I was
probably a witch in a past life and
guess what I'm not even gonna finish the
sentence so I don't know yeah she was a
what I mean sure there was a relative
who was what was she hanging us at which
she was accused of being a witch okay
and I won't tell you what happens to her
oh okay I think you did with the thing
around the neck
well that's Jean feeling doing but
that's gonna link back to something in
the past their ghostly news from the
past
yes all right so I ruined it for you you
could have had some oh oh yeah sorry my
people weren't getting hanged left and
right persecution for a bunch of Irish
hillbillies
you